[Musique]
bonjour samedi 29 avril 12h30
c'est évident on va parler de fromage de
chèvre car vous ne le saviez peut-être
pas mais il y a une saison pour les
fromages de chèvre ça commence
maintenant et ça se termine à la fin de
l'automne
tout le reste des fromages de chèvre que
vous mangez pendant l'hiver sont faits à
partir de cahiers surgelés donc s'il
vous plaît s'il vous plaît
à partir de maintenant il ya d'autres
fromages pour l'hiver mais pas les
chèvres ânes et est maintenant printemps
automne pour parler d'un fromage de
chèvre à côté de moi jean allard jean
allard et chevrier et jean on s'est
connu à arolla ya plus de 25 ans mais
quand je t'ai connu on se tutoie tu ne
tu n'étais pas chevrier elle raconte que
moi ce qui t'a amené au chèvre en fait
aussi bien simple j'étais dans les
années 60 au début des années 60
marchand de fromages aux halles
centrales de paris les anciennes halles
qui ont disparu aujourd'hui nous
cherchons des spécialités de bons
fromages et éventuellement des fromages
de chèvre et surtout des fromages de
chèvre j'ai eu un ami chevrier qui en
fabriquer de petites quantités qui m'a
dit si tu veux que je te fasse davantage
viennent m'aider avec moi j'ai cherché
une spéculation
je ne vais pas trouver mais j'ai trouvé
une passion et depuis je ne m'occupe
plus que de mes chèvres et de ses
fromages du cher il en train de
prononcer un mot dur qui veut dire
passion alors ce qui veut dire qu'il
faut aimer ses chèvres m'enfin on peut
aimer un chat un chat mais une chèvre
quand même mais une chèvre c'est
extrêmement attachant tu sais on dit
toujours qu'il faut être un peu farfelue
pour aimer riche et parce qu'elles sont
capricieuses mais si on veut qu'elle
nous donne un peu de lait il faut s'en
occuper particulièrement il faut les
choyer les bichonner tu vois un petit
peu tu veux dire que si tu t'occupes
d'une chèvre si tu l'aimais ne te
donnera plus de lait que notre héroïne
comme en amour il faut beaucoup donné
pour recevoir un peu d'élégance et
chèvres tu les connais alors tu les
appelles est ce qu'elles ont dénoncé
chez m
bien sûr qu'elles ont des noms je linky
le shit a jamais eu qui s'appelle magali
van est et puis j'ai la reine du
troupeau qui s'appelle mistoufle est
elle à elle est la fille et la petite
fille d'une autre mistoufle est nous les
retrouvons touche toujours
et puis j'ai églantine une vieille dame
maintenant tu sais mais que nous gardons
pas plaisir il ya une chose que je
voudrais vous dire
savez vous combien il faut de lait pour
faire ce petit fromage de chèvre d'état
de des fromages d'ailleurs eh bien il
faut un litre et demi à deux litres de
lait pour faire se frotte réserve là
celui là encore tu peux le prendre je
connais pas ça l'est encore su nativa le
salé et puis après il va il va y avoir
un problème là on commence à donner
envie aux gens dans le premier je veux
te dire une chose je t'écoute je te vois
que superbe
j'ai envie de partir faire du fromage de
chèvre alors est-ce que c'est facile
parce que c'est ça c'est le réveil des
petits oiseaux ces merveilleuses est
extraordinaire c'est facile c'est pas
facile non c'est très difficile en fait
si tu veux il faut avoir d'abord une
première qualité beaucoup de courage se
lever de bonne heure le matin et finir
tard le soir car il faut laisser 12
heures entre la première et la deuxième
traite donc tu vois nous commençons à 6
heures du matin et nous recommençons le
soir à six heures du soir et comme il
faut trois heures pour faire un troupeau
tu vois que lança nous fait terminé donc
il faut être très attaché et avoir le
plaisir de son métier car il n'y a pas
de dimanche qui a pas de jour de fête il
faut travailler
donc il faut avoir l'amour de ce métier
l'aimé et vivre dedans en permanence oui
alors bon ça c'est formidable donc tu
fais de bons fromages de chèvre
mais il ya aussi des mauvais fromage de
chèvre ça existe tu vas pas me dire le
contraire
alors expliquez moi comment pour le
public qui va acheté dans un magasin
comment peut-on reconnaître à l'oeil un
bon fromage de chèvre d'un mauvais tu
peux me le premier moyen si tu veux
c'est de faire confiance à nos craignais
qu'ils sont quand même des gens de
métier c'est la première des choses la
deuxième meilleur étiquetage une
législation
il ya des fromages fermiers et des
fromages laitiers lait fromages fermiers
que nous fabriquons pour tous sur leurs
étiquettes produits à la ferme fromages
fermiers à partir de là c'est quand même
une garantie broco somme c'est à dire
que les fromages fermiers sont faits à
partir de dans un seul endroit avec le
lait de tes chèvres et
les fromages laitiers parce que moi le
mot les kiss ça veut dire des choses
bien ils sont faits en fromagerie cela
si tu veux avec délice de mélange avec
des les ramasser qui ont refroidi qui
ont été plus ou moins de casser et donc
des fromages qui ne seront pas mauvais
mais qui n'auront pas le cru qu'ils
n'auront pas le goût du lait chocolat en
présiderait tout de suite voilà le
problème
d'accord alors pour faire moi
aujourd'hui le gâteau au fromage blanc
j'ai utilisé du fromage de chèvre frais
mais vous pouvez utiliser n'importe quel
fromage blanc voilà la recette elle
commence superbe gâteau au fromage blanc
pour au moins six personnes il faut
commencer par faire à la pâte
car cette pâte et elle non friable
tellement délicate tellement subtil que
pour l'étendre il faut qu'elle ait eu
deux heures de réfrigérateur avant alors
voilà j'ai 50 g de beurre bien ramolli
bien drame on line je tiens à le
préciser
je mets ce beurre dans un saladier j'y
ajoute une cuiller à soupe bien pointu
de sucre en poudre et vous le savez pour
les gâteaux il faut toujours ajouter une
pincée de sel petit petit petit voir et
avec un faux la main je vais mélanger
sober bien ramolli avec le sucre en
poudre
jusqu'à ce que ce beurre voyez ça y est
c'est parti commencent à blanche
aussitôt que le beurre on commence à
blanchir je cassais 9 dans le beurre est
à nouveau je mélange et je mélange mais
va nier fermement il faut que sa balle
en touche il se tout ça chez nous on dit
faut que ça sente l'aïe
en fait ça sans jamais lie mais ça veut
dire que c'est jamais assez battu voilà
vont mélanger bien blanc j'enlève le fou
et je n'ai plus besoin
et maintenant j'ajoute 120 g de farine
et avec la cuillère en bois
je mélange doucement tout ce mois en
venir faire j'essaye de mélanger
doucement
cette farine avec le mélange duff de
beurre et de sucre et j'obtiens une pâte
qui va être un peu mon las à la fin je
vais terminer avec la main pour faire
une boule et cette boule de pâte
une fois que je vais l'avoir fait je
vais la mettre dans l'assiette et la
mettre au réfrigérateur pour deux heures
voilà la boule de pâte est terminée
faut pas la travailler cette pâte il
faut qu'elle soit juste en petites
boules comme ça et je vais mettre cette
pâte au réfrigérateur pour 2 real même
temps que je fais ça j'ai mis 3
cuillères à soupe de raisins de smyrne
dans un verre j ajoute 2 cuillères à
soupe de rhum l'argent en en mettant par
tous comme d'habitude d'un ami vaille et
je vais laisser macérer ses raisins de
smyrne dans leurs hommes pour qu'ils
gonflent dents
et dans deux heures je vais commencer
réellement à faire le gâteau au fromage
blanc
alors pour faire l'intérieur du gâteau
au fromage blanc et il y a bien sûr les
raisins de smyrne qui sont trompés dans
leurs hommes il y à 300 g de fromage
blanc moi j'ai pris du fromage frais de
chèvre il faut 2 cuillères à soupe de
crème fraîche 3e 3 cuillères à soupe de
farine 120 g de sucre en poudre c'est à
dire 5 cuillères à soupe une cuillère à
café de levure chimique et puis ensuite
une cuillère à café de cannelle
je viens de sortir ma boule de pâte du
réfrigérateur ça fait deux heures
qu'elle y est voyez elle est bien dure
elle est parfaite
et puis c'est 300 g de fromage blanc et
goûteux je tiens à vous le dire il est
dégoûté ce fromage c'est du chèvre pour
moi mais on peut le faire avec n'importe
quel fromage blanc j'y ajoute dans ce
saladier sur le fromage blanc de beurre
2 cuillères à soupe de crème fraîche et
puis avec un fouet je mélange pour
obtenir une pâte bien lisse c'est très
vite envoyé voilà aussitôt que ce
mélange effet dans un deuxième saladier
je casse 3e et 3 et sur ses 3 e j'ajoute
120 g de sucre en poudre c'est à dire 5
cuillères à soupe de sucre en poudre
bien pleine 3 4 et 5 quai avec un fouet
jeu bape ses oeufs avec le sucre en
poudre jusqu'à ce que encore une fois le
mélange blanchisse
c'est également très bas
voilà une fois que ça ait fait j'ai un
petit bol et dans ce petit bol je mets
trois cuillères à soupe de farine
mignonne ce pas la peine de les faire
trop pointu j'ajoute de dans une
cuillère à café de levure chimique et
puis petit c'est pas la peine d'en être
trop je mélange délicatement ma levure
chimique à ma farine
c'est important sinon entre l'as wihr
chimiques resterait dans un coin du
gâteau et n'irait pas partie et puis
maintenant le contenu du saladier
c'est à dire sucre et du pe blanchi
directement dans le mélange fromage
blanc immédiatement derrière le contenu
du petit bol c'est à dire farine et
levure et doucement doucement petit à
petit on mélange le tout
voyez on obtient une pâte un peu molle
pas trop mal mais un peu molle en la
fouettent légèrement
c'est fini on n'a plus besoin du fouet
et souvenez vous de ces raisins regardez
les ils sont gonflés dans le rhum on
ajoute ces raisins gonfler dans le rhum
dans la pâte et avec une spatule en
caoutchouc d'où ce monde pour ne pas
casser cette pâte on mélange les raisins
trompés dans leurs hommes à la pâte et
là ça y est on est prêt à mettre la pâte
dans le moule et à verser ceci à
l'intérieur du moule et à mettre au four
la pâte est devant moi elle est donc
froide
je vais la poser sur une table fariné et
avec un rouleau je vais étaler cette
pâte voyez j'ai beurré l'intérieur d'un
moule avec une cuillère à café de beurre
et l'important pour moi c'est de faire
une pâte plus large de façon à ce
qu'elles rendre dans l'intérieur du
moule lequel débordante
donc j'ai talent d'où ce nom alors le
plus dur pour étaler une patte c'est de
l'étaler en effet pour qu'ils n'en
perdent pas donc la seule façon de le
faire c'est chaque fois de donner un
demi-tour à votre panier
alors là la patte
il faut encore un tout petit peu plus le
talent et maintenant je sais pas si vous
savez faire comment fait-on pour m la
fatale intérieure demeure c'est très
simple regardez on roule la patte sur le
rouleau et on la pose délicatement on
l'a déroule sur le moule et puis là on a
plus qu'à d'où ce nom comme elle est
très fragile rentré la pâte à
l'intérieur du moule appuyer un petit
peu et là regardez il ya un truc c'est
tout simple avec le rouleau vous appuyez
comme ceux ci est automatiquement autres
pâtes et décrocher
des bords du moule maintenant elle est
parfaite
les superbes il n'ya plus qu'à verser à
l'intérieur tout notre mélange ça va
juste remplir
parce que cammas avait un petit peu
gonflé samar événement arrivé au bord du
moulin
et puis je vais porter semoule au four
qui est préchauffé doux thermostat 5
pour une demi heure est au bout d'une
demi heure ça va finir la cuisson
je monterai le moule thermostat 6 pour
20 minutes donc totale de la cuisson 50
minutes
j'apporte mon nouveau four ça y est 50
minutes au four le grand moment est
arrivé regarder ce gâteau qui sort du
four il est superbe
il est gonflé mais pour qu'ils restent
gonflé il ya un truc un papier
d'aluminium que j'ai beurré largement
beurré je pose ce papier d'aluminium sur
mon gars tu ouvriers délicatement
je vais poser tant il faut revenir vers
ici si vous pouvez me suivre je vais
poser je vais prendre le gâteau je vais
poser une assiette dessus voilà
et d'un coup d'un seul je vais retourner
le gâteau et puis là je vais enlever le
moule et le gâteau va refroidir
retourner pourquoi parce que si je le
laisser refroidir tel quel dans le moule
et bien il redescendrait il deviendrait
creux comme un vieux souffler comme un
béret basque avachi alors pour lui
garder cette belle forme ronde gelé mis
sur ce papier beurré et je les retourne
et sur une assiette et de cette façon là
il va rester bien plein dans le dans le
moule et au bout de deux heures
quand je vais leur tournée sur le plat
de service il sera parfait eh bien le
voilà le gâteau le voilà deux heures
après on l'a retourné et qu'est ce que
j'ai fait je laisse ou pleurer avec une
cuillère à café de cannelle en poudre
attention c'est un gâteau pour 6
personnes il n'a pas l'air gros comme ça
mais comme on dit chez nous jean ça
tient ou encore un
alors je vais te le fais route et oui
j'irai au la haine je sais que tu as
fait on commence à parler dessert
aujourd'hui
[Rires]
merci et pendant que tu vas le goûter je
vais continuer mon suivez le goûter
après je vais continuer à rappeler les
choses importantes au goutte à goutte de
ce qu'on a dit la grosse différence
c'est le mot fermiers sur les fromages
de chèvre ça il faut vous en souvenir
et la deuxième chose c'est les saisons
alors là les saisons pour le fromage de
chèvre on va le rappeler jean mars à
octobre après après il vaut mieux
s'arrêter il vaut mieux ça vaut mieux
manger autre chose voilà un sens entre
façon la cetp il faut dire aussi aux
gens que s'ils en étaient ils mangent
beaucoup de fromages de chèvre jusqu'en
octobre
et bien il ne restera plus de ce fameux
cahiers qu'on ne fera plus surgelés pour
le manger en hiver est bon dit entendre
bon appétit à merci
[Musique]